bon jean guillaume larrivé bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être invités politiques ce
matin des piquets les républicains de
l'yonne on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour pascal jalabert nique
du groupe ebra les journaux régionaux de
l'est de la france on va commencer
évidemment en parlant de la nouvelle
calédonie guillaume larrivé le non à
l'indépendance là donc largement emporté
hier en nouvelle calédonie plus de 96%
des voix mais une forte abstention et ce
score in s'explique par le fait que les
indépendantistes ont boycotté le scrutin
est ce que pour vous ce scrutin tout de
même légitimité politique bien sûr je
suis pas du tout sur la ligne de jean
luc mélenchon qui disait hier ce
référendum utile guy team parce que 60%
des gens n'ont pas partie des noms ce
que je veux retenir moi c'est une chance
très simple c'est que la france d outre
mer c'est la france en grand moi je suis
heureux lorsque nos compatriotes de
nouvelle calédonie font le choix de
rester ce qu'ils sont à nos côtés
maintenant ce que je sais c'est qu'en
application des accords matignon s'ouvre
devant nous une période qui va mettre
une période de discussion de
consolidation de la place de la nouvelle
calédonie dans la république française
voilà mais c'est important c'est
important que la france se pense comme
une nation présente sur tous les
continents sur cet aprem et l'appel au
boycott des indépendantistes il a donc
été massivement suivi le résultat est ce
qu'il faut regarder ça autrement que
comme un simple désintérêt ce qu'il faut
y voir un vrai message politique il ya
peu sur une expression dans l'abstention
il faut la regarder pour ce qu'elle est
elle existe mais il ya aussi
et un suffrage qui s'est exprimée qui
s'est exprimé à trois reprises je
rappelle qu'il ya eu un référendum
deuxième référendum un troisième
référendum et ses trois préfèrent un dom
ont tous les trois confirmait le choix
majoritaire des néo-calédoniens de
rester français au sein de notre
république maintenant encore une fois il
faut s'en réjouir parce que la france
qui veut qui doit peser comme puissance
au sein du monde la france à cet atout
formidable des territoires collectivités
pays d'outre-mer qui sont très divers
mais qui permettent d'exprimer la voix
française en effet se plaît sur tous les
continents alors justement dans la
région indo pacifique avec la chine qui
va être de plus en plus présente ça vous
inquiète tous c'est un jeu stratégique
dans ce secteur il ya le nickel mais il
ya aussi bine un peu cette guerre larvée
cette guerre froide chine-etats-unis
euros un peu beaucoup si je dis en
réalité on assiste à un basculement de
l'ordre du monde autour d'un axe lax
asiatique et pacifique et il est très
important pour nous puissances
européennes d'avoir avec la nouvelle
calédonie mais aussi avec la polynésie
française des points qui sont plus que
des points d'appui qui sont des points
de présence dans des points de
rayonnement c'est très important au plan
maritime mais bien au delà c'est très
important au plan géostratégique que la
france soit soit présente dans cet
endroit tellement important pour
l'avenir du monde mais quand vous voyez
que les indépendantistes il refuse de
reconnaître la légitimité de ce scrutin
il refuse de rencontrer sébastien
lecornu les autres maires qui est
actuellement sur place mais quand j'ai
regardé l'eau quand j'ai regardé une
déclaration je crois que le prennent en
compte aussi le calendrier qui est celui
du grand rendez vous démocratique que
nous aurons au printemps en france j'ai
regardé hier la dépêche afp n est ce pas
qui indique de la part des
indépendantistes le souhait de reprendre
le dialogue avec les autorités
françaises qui seront issues des
élections présidentielles voilà je mets
mais je constate ce n'est qu'une
continuité de l'état et jeu mais ils ont
peut-être un peu tort de ne pas discuter
avec les autorités du moment mes fans ne
nous arrêtons pas ce qui est pour moi
secondaires
non mais encore heureux bon moi je
souhaite naturellement que le dialogue
républicain continue à ceux à se faire
sans perdre de vue l'essentiel la france
d outre mer c'est la france en grand on
doit on peut se réjouir sincèrement de
ce que la nouvelle calédonie et fait le
choix de poursuivre ce chemin aux côtés
des français nous sommes les
compatriotes des des néo-calédoniens et
c'est important qu'ils aient fait ce
choix majeurs on va parler de la crise
sanitaire puisque la france est est
frappé de plein fouet par la cinquième
vague et il ya eu les événements
parisiens il disait ceci grâce au plan
blanc on va augmenter le nombre de nids
mais on pourra peut-être pas accueillir
autant de malades en réanimation que
lors des premières vagues est ce que
vous êtes inquiet pour la situation de
l'hôpital aujourd'hui oui et je le dis
vraiment sans esprit polémique mais je
suis inquiet je le voit d'ailleurs dans
mon département de l'yonne où nous avons
un centre hospitalier j'ai changé avec
des médecins et des infirmiers ces jours
derniers je suis inquiet parce que
tension une tension des équipes une
tension des matériels il ya une crise
structurelle de l'hôpital public et au
delà d'ailleurs du système de soins
c'est une réalité très préoccupante
alors même que la nation consacrent une
part très importante de sa richesse de
son pib aux dépenses nécessaires de
santé on voit bien qu'il ya des tensions
et oui bien sûr je suis préoccupé au
milieu de cette cinquième vague je suis
aussi quand même un peu surpris que
bientôt deux ans après le début de
l'épidémie de coded on se pose parfois
sur le terrain les mêmes questions faute
peut-être quand même pour le ministère
de la santé et pour olivier ferrand
d'avoir su depuis deux ans pilotait la
réorganisation pratique fonctionnelle de
l'hôpital donc ça veut dire qu'il ya eu
un échec la suède ça veut dire qu'il ya
des sujets de préoccupations sur la
vaccination des enfants qui doit débuter
cette semaine pour les enfants les plus
fragiles est ce que vous vous êtes
favorable à cette vaccination des
enfants généralisée si évidemment la
haute autorité donne son feu vert j'ai
une règle depuis le début de cette
épidémie c'est que je ne me prends pas
pour l'académie de médecine pour le
conseil scientifique ou pour d'autres
autorités et par conséquent je pense que
les responsables publics
ont un devoir d'humilité surtout
lorsqu'on n'est pas directement aux
manettes je n'ai pas le même degré
d'information que l'académie de médecine
que le conseil scientifique je propose
donc plutôt de s'en remettre à la
sagesse de ces autorités ce n'est pas
moi qui vais vous parlement souvenirs
d'amours avoir toutes les informations
vous trouvez ça normal je considère que
le parlement doit évidemment faire son
travail de contrôle mais chacun est dans
son rôle je trouve parfois disons le un
peu ridicule
la concurrence des diafoirus qui ne
sachant pas grand chose sur les
questions scientifiques tiennent
absolument à ce que cela se sache
je pense at espèce de concours qu'on a
vu depuis deux ans où les mêmes qui
s'improvisent épidémiologistes se disent
ensuite d'ailleurs spécialiste de
l'afghanistan dont nous sommes des
généralistes certes mais je pense qu'il
faut que chacun reste à sa place et moi
je ne suis pas membre de l'académie de
médecine et parce que je respecte les
français je n'ai pas envie de dire
n'importe quoi sur cette question de
vaccination je n'ai pas moi des vies
scientifiques sur la vaccination des
enfants et c'est plutôt rassurant que je
le dise je pense qu'il faut que les
responsables politiques soient dans
leurs champs et leurs champs ça n'est
pas celui de l'expression scientifique
direct alors on va parler pouvoir
d'achat donc à partir de ce matin les
étudiants commencent à toucher cette
femme et un ami telle relation de 200
euros d'abord est-ce que vous êtes
favorable et est ce que c'est un bon
système pour corriger les hausses des
prix assez subite
je peux comprendre évidemment pas ce que
je fais sur le terrain j'étais récemment
discuté avec des étudiants en école
d'infirmière pour le coup et certaines
d'entre elles me disaient que elle avait
besoin de colis alimentaires pour
boucler les fins de mois dont je vois
bien qu'il ya un sujet après 1h38 le
français les bleus touché mais ne
perdons pas de vue que 60% à peu près de
la richesse nationale est redistribué
sous forme de dépenses publiques
aujourd'hui moi mon modèle c'est pas
l'union soviétique on va pas
collectiviser tout le système si on veut
retrouver dans la durée du pouvoir
d'achat il faut créer des richesses il
faut innover il faut des entreprises qui
comptent hier des marchés voilà je
voudrais pas qu'on perde de vue
al'approche des échéances électorales la
politique du chèque la politique de la
distri lution d'échec va vite trouvé ses
limites alors justement valérie pécresse
qui était invité du grand jury la
semaine dernière elle disait ce n'est
pas normal qu'avec emmanuel macron soit
devenue une société d'assistés qui
vivent de chèques pour payer l'essence
vous approuver cette phrase oui ma jeu
je pense qu'il faut respecter les
français et ce serait mentir
ce serait mentir que de promettre sur
les plateaux ou sur les tréteaux la
multiplication des chèques ça ne peut
pas fonctionner lancement dans la gérer
chaque essence ces huiles essentielles
pour les français c'est à court terme
évidemment bien reçu par la personne qui
le reçoit mais du point de vue de
l'intérêt collectif du point de vue de
l'intérêt national je ne suis pas
partisan de la multiplication de ce
qu'on appelle les dépenses
d'intervention la multiplication des
chèques la multiplication des z je pense
que un pays le nôtre qui est un grand
pays sa force ça doit être la création
de richesse par les entreprises doit
être l'innovation ça doit être la
croissance c'est pas des abstractions
dans la durée c'est comme ça que ça va
fonctionner l'argent n'est pas magique
on un peu entretenu depuis quelques
années les françaises et des français
dans l'illusion de l'argent magique que
ce qu'il ya une politique monétaire qui
est très expansive et une politique
budgétaire qui est complètement à
guichet ouvert aux plans conjoncturels
c'était nécessaire lorsqu'il ya eu ce
choc de la queue vide en 2020 d'investir
et d'injecter de l'argent public dans
l'économie nationale mais il va falloir
je vous le dis sortir progressivement
intelligemment cette espèce de seringue
progressivement
je considère que la situation des
finances publiques est extrêmement
dégradée que notre responsabilité c'est
d'être raisonnable et de ne pas raconter
n'importe quoi vous savez moi j'ai pas
trop de respect pour les hommes ou les
femmes politiques qui racontent
n'importe quoi qui promettent des
chèques tout le temps moi je suis
associé juste faut-il baisser les impôts
c'est quand eric ciotti elle avait
proposé il faut une baisse des impôts
est ce que c'est possible
évidemment
en même temps
rationaliser les dépenses publiques et
réussir à faire baisser la pression
fiscale sur tous ceux qui produisent des
richesses bien sûr je vous le confirme
ce matin pas du tout
ça n'a absolument rien contradictoire
c'est tout à fait réfléchie et sérieux
que de chercher à maîtriser les dépenses
publiques à diminuer certaines dépenses
publiques le montant par exemple des
aides aux entreprises je crois que ses
14 points 5 milliards d'euros chaque
année bon moi je le dis aux chefs
d'entreprise aux acteurs consulaires
dans le territoire dont je suis l'élu
soyons cohérents on peut pas demander
des aides et demander la baisse des
impôts moi je suis favorable à une
société de liberté c'est aussi le projet
que porte valérie pécresse je me
retrouve d'ailleurs tout à fait dans ce
projet que d'un projet de liberté nous
devons réussir à rationaliser la dépense
publique on la transforme des impôts
s'est passé pas dans son projet
rationaliser la dépense publique et être
capable d'avoir un certain nombre
d'évolutions du taux de prélèvements
obligatoires notre modèle n'est pas un
modèle socialiste justement puisqu'on
parle de valérie pécresse hier gérald
darmanin était l'invité du grand jury et
l'adie de valérie pécresse c'est une
bonne candidate pour versailles mais
elle ne parle pas aux électeurs de
tourcoing qu'est ce que venait de cette
phrase alors j'ai une certaine amitié
pour gérald darmanin je veux pas faire
un concours de petites phrases mais je
crois me souvenir et je me souviens même
très bien nous étions député ensemble
qu'en 2013-2014 gérald darmanin était
assez heureux de recevoir valérie
pécresse précisément à tourcoing pour sa
campagne municipale donc cette petite
phrase n'est qu'une petite phrase à
propos
de campagne quand vous savez qu'une
petite phrase est ce que ça traduit pas
le remettre qu'elle parle à une certaine
catégorie de français qu'elle ne parle
pas aux classes populaires chansons
mais c'est encore une fois c'est une une
forme et je crois pas du tout je crois
qu'on tient que valérie pécresse
pour laquelle j'ai appelé à voter avant
le premier tour de la primaire je le
rappelle je pense qu'elle est au coeur
de la droite française une droite
raisonnable une droite sérieuse
raisonnable ça veut pas dire mollassonne
mais je pense qu'elle a une capacité à
présenter un projet susceptible de
rassembler une large majorité de
français mais c'est moche et lui d'un
territoire qui est un territoire rural
député de la circonscription qui compte
sens petites villes et villages elle est
aussi la présidente du conseil régional
d'île de france la france et tout ça
c'est les villes et les campagnes et je
pense qu'il faut pas du tout la réduire
je ne sais quelle caricature tout sonne
à tout ça n'a pas de sens et j'appelle
d'ailleurs chacun dans la majorité
aujourd'hui à garder son sang froid je
pense que le péché d'arrogance traduit
de la part d'un certain nombre de
responsables de la majorité actuelle
beaucoup de fébrilité notamment de la
part des deux ailes socialiste de la
majorité je regardais ce qu'a dit
monsieur à thalmann amichia pas monsieur
véran monsieur castaner l'ale socialiste
de la majorité je trouve
particulièrement agressive serait-elle
nostalgiques des années hollande je ne
veux pas le croire
on a bien compris pour vous
de france elle a tenu oui parce que je
veux juste un point là dessus son
approche précisément n'est pas une
approche catégorielles c'est pas une
espèce d' approche de marketing qui
consiste à regarder une étude d'opinion
dont il ya telle catégorie faut lui dire
ça il ya telle catégorie et lui dire ça
là c'est pas ça
certains font cela a manifestement c'est
pas ça hélène approche va dire et écrire
une approche nationale il s'agit de
présenter aux français aux françaises
une perspective une perspective positive
pour la france d'aujourd'hui et pour la
france de demain c'est pas dans les
outrances de monsieur zemmour c'était
mieux avant va tous mourir c'est pas une
espèce de nostalgie un peu rabougri non
c'est pas ça c'est pas non plus une
espèce de
d'immobilisme en réalité qu on rencontre
parfois dans le pouvoir actuel qui a pas
tenu ses moins qu'on puisse dire toutes
ses promesses de transformation annoncé
un projet positif qui va s'adresser à
l'ensemble des juges des français pour
réconcilier la france avec elle même
avec son destin de puissance pour
rétablir l'ordre dans les comptes et
dans la rue très bonne formule d'edouard
philippe edouard philippe a dit que
dans la rue mais c'est le projet que
nous avons avec valérie pécresse
justement comment on fait pour parler à
ses électeurs qui peuvent être tentés
paris zemmour par marine le pen et en
même temps par balles et aura de
centre-droit quatre jours que
dispensable soyons nous mêmes soyons
cette droite sérieuses à droite de
gouvernement qui est capable à la fois
de gérer le ministère de l'intérieur
pour réduire l'immigration pour
restaurer la sécurité publique qui est
capable aussi de réorganiser le service
public de la justice on a tellement
besoin donc marchons sur cette jambe
régaliennes et nous avons pour cela
l'expérience valérie pécresse a su
s'entourer de patrick stefanini de
frédéric péchenard l'ancien directeur
général de la police nationale l'auteur
d' équipe
eric ciotti dit le premier tour il va se
jouer à droite c'est à droite qu'il faut
regarder disais hier jean-christophe
lagarde de lui dit consciente des
visions est ce que pour vous il faut
aller vers la droite et oublier le
centre il faut je vous le répète parce
que je viens de vous le dire être ce que
nous sommes nous sommes à la fois une
droite capable de rétablir l'ordre dans
la rue et une droite capable de rétablir
l'ordre dans les comptes nous sommes
aussi cette droite de liberté qui fait
confiance aux entrepreneurs qui fait
confiance à tous ceux qui veulent
innover qui veulent créer qui veulent
peser dans la mondialisation tout à
l'heure je disais à propos de la
nouvelle calédonie la france d outre mer
c'est la france en grand nous voulons
aussi être une équipe autour de valérie
pécresse capable d'avoir un projet
positif pour la france pour les libertés
pour les territoires de france on veut
aussi offrir des perspectives aux
français c'est les deux et on a besoin
des deux dans notre pays on a besoin
d'ordre régaliens on a besoin aussi
d'ordre dans les comtés de liberté
économique et c'est comme ça en étant
nous mêmes qu'on parlera à tous les
français il s'agit pas de se lever le
matin en disant est ce que je suis
plutôt de droite est ce que je fais
plutôt de centre-droit il s'agit de
fédérer une majorité de français
raisonnable qui a envie que la france
continue à être ce qu'elle est
c'est-à-dire une puissance une puissance
en paix avec elle même
si cela dure guantanamo à la française
il a dit que ce cas dans le programme de
valérie pécresse à savoir la rétention
de sûreté qui l'avait proposée avec vous
d'ailleurs finalement ça lui convient il
a fait une erreur la française il ya une
chose très simple c'est que il n'a pas
lui eric ciotti parlait de ouvrez les
guillemets continue à la française c'est
une de vos concerts aux confrères du
journal le point qui lui a posé une
question d'ambiance mots et d'ensuite
christian bale il n'a pas repris sur le
fond sur le fond nous sommes tous
d'accord pour dire quoi ça fait des
années qu'on le dit eric ciotti et moi
nous étions allés en israël en août 2016
faire un voyage d'étude et après ce
voyage on avait en réfléchissant avec
des juristes des parties siens des
policiers comme on le fait depuis plein
d'années nous avions considéré qu'il
était nécessaire de dire aux françaises
et aux français attention des bombes
humaines vont être libérés de prison ces
bombes humaines ce sont des terroristes
djihadistes qui ont été condamnés à des
peines de prison
et ces peines de prison arrivant à leur
terme ces jihadistes vont être libérés
ce que nous proposons avec valérie
pécresse avec eric ciotti avec d'autres
c'est une rétention une rétention
décidée par l'autorité judiciaire il
faudrait qu'un juge haddock j'appelle ça
un juge de la sécurité nationale juge de
la sûreté nationale qui serait à a créé
peut-être un jld spécialisé enfin bref
un juge haddock prendrai la décision
oriane mancini de maintenir dans un lieu
fermé en rétention certains jihadistes
après la sortie de prison c'est une
mesure de sûreté ce n'est pas une peine
et c'est une mesure en réalité
d'enfermement permettant en effet de
mettre hors d'état de nuire ces
djihadistes qui veulent nous détruire et
nous convergeons absolument là dessus
c'est dans le programme aujourd'hui de
valérie pécresse la suppression du droit
du sol vous êtes favorable j'ai été
l'auteur à titre personnel dès 2013
d'une proposition de loi
faisant évoluer le droit de la
nationalité
je pense que tout ce qui permet de se
rapprocher de cette belle idée
d'assimilation qui figurent dans cette
déjà dans le code civil et qui notamment
figurent dans le code civil tel qu'il a
été rétablie en 1945 par le gouvernement
provisoire général de gaulle tout ce qui
permet de rapprocher en réalité des
processus d'acquisition de la
nationalité de ce critère d'assimilation
ça me convient je suis contre les
automatismes je suis favorable à ce que
lorsque l'on né en france de parents
étrangers on ne devienne français en que
par un choix une adhésion à la
communauté nationale 1 un projet c'est
dans la logique profondément
républicaines c'est dans celle de renan
du reste le projet national c'est un
projet d'adhésion et ça je trouve ça
très positif parce que ça donne des
perspectives qui sont des perspectives
formidables qui sont des perspectives à
la fois très nationale est très
républicaine sur et les émois
je reviens à ce qu'a dit eric ciotti
alors il dit que valérie pécresse et il
est convaincu qu'elle sera au second
tour mais que si un second tour est mon
mac rond il réaffirme qu'il battra pour
eric zemmour c'est un problème pour vous
moi je pense que nous ne devons pas nous
placer dans ses hypothèses là nous
sommes à cent vingt et quelques jours du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle nous avons une candidate
de grande valeur valérie pécresse que
nous avons collectivement choisi de
présenter moi je pense
à créer un problème chacun doit
consacrer son énergie à gagner cette
grande bataille du premier tour pour que
valérie soit qualifié au second tour et
quelle est la capacité à être la
première présidente de la république
française voilà ce que je veux dire ce
matin sur pause et je me suis exprimée
dès le mois de septembre avec beaucoup
d'honnêteté je ne voterai pour ma part
jamais pour eric zemmour ni au premier
ni au deuxième niveau 3e ligne au
quatrième ni au 5e tour nous avons avec
lui des différences qui sont des
différences irréconciliables
je n'apprécie pas du tout c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire la manière avec
laquelle il a mis du sel sur les plaies
de l'histoire le projet de la droite
autour de valérie pécresse aujourd'hui
le projet de la droite républicaine la
droite de gouvernement ça doit être la
réconciliation nationale ça n'est pas la
fracturation ça n'est pas la division
nous ne sommes pas naïfs et nous
regardons la france telle qu'elle est je
vois bien que la france est déchirée
quand même manteau d'arlequin je vois
bien le retour de la lutte des classes
je vois bien l'émergence d'une lutte des
pseudos race je vois bien la persistance
d'une lutte des espaces d'une des
territoires ya beaucoup de
fractionnement il ya cet archipel
isation de la france est bien face à
cela notre projet c'est un projet
positif de reconstruction de la nation
non c'est parce que je vous dis nous
avons notre propre constat j'ai pas
entendu monsieur et mots pour
m'intéresser aux questions de sécurité
ou aux questions de justice je n'ai pas
du tout à me positionner par rapport à
lui nous sommes lucides nous autour de
valérie pécresse sur l'état de la france
sur le ordre dans les comptes et le
désordre dans la rue constat que
d'autres partagent y compris edouard
philippe et face à cela nous avons
autour de valérie pécresse un projet de
reconstruction nationale pas un projet
de division un projet de fracturation
donc je l' ai déjà dit je le répète eric
zemmour ne pas être traité comme un
allié potentiel ni même comme un
concurrent et peut-être traité en
adversaire notre projet pour la france
n'est pas le sien nous avons un projet
positif susceptible j'en suis persuadée
de rassembler de fédérer une majorité de
françaises et français qui ont envie que
la france reste ce qu'elle est
c'est-à-dire une grande nation une
nation puissante une nation en paix avec
elle même merci beaucoup merci d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin
[Musique]